je pense qu'il ya eu je mets tous je dis
toujours qu'il ya eu un changement
violent dans le système économique en
europe j'ai pas si mes collègues
partagent cet avis si l'arrivée au
pouvoir de madame thatcher puis de
monsieur régal qui l'a fait que stephen
âmes cette chaire est donc on est passé
d'un système où en gros on accepter les
régulations de marche fort on avait une
économie contrôlée par l'état je fais
très simple on a voulu tout déréglementé
et ça aussi il faut quand même bien voir
que l'union européenne c'est d'une part
cette volonté politique de rassembler
les pays mais c'est aussi la volonté de
créer un marché donc et cette volonté a
été transférée ont créé un marché pour
le pétrole à la limite pourquoi pas mais
il existait d'ailleurs de toute façon on
décide de libéraliser le prix de
l'essence comme on l'a fait en 86
pourquoi pas c'est pas totalement
dramatique d'avis que ça va monter à 2
euros bon c'est ce qu'on voit que ça
bouge mais et je suis tout à fait
d'accord ça peut avoir des conséquences
on l'a vu il ya trois ans régis et j'ose
avoir des conséquences importantes ni
empêche que le problème c'est que on est
sur les marchés du gaz sur le
fonctionnement du système gaz
électricité ce qu'on appelle des
monopoles naturels vous êtes chez vous
vous avez d'électricité on va pas être
de ligne de cou ligue l'occurrence pour
vous approvisionner donc on a mis en
place l'union européenne où il ya des
maniaques se dirait un petit peu du
marché à tout prix ont voulu absolument
appliquer à ces monopoles naturels et
même réel qu'on applique à la
marchandise qui sont les ventes de
pommes de betterave ou bien de bien des
sens et ça ça se traduit par des
systèmes extrêmement compliqué
[Musique]